I am Legend is about a zombie-like horde
wiping out much of humanity but it's
confusing ending and butterfly symbolism
become a lot more clear if you
understand the personal journey of its
hero created by genetically altering
measles the cryptid virus seemed like a
miracle cure unfortunately after its
initial promise the virus mutates with
catastrophic results the virus kills 5.4
billion people with 5% transformed into
zombie or vampire like dark seekers 1%
of the population remains immune which
includes Neville a viral adjust for the
u.s. army played by Will Smith Neville
remains in New York City after it is
placed in military quarantine
although Neville is nearly entirely
alone in New York he still got his
faithful dog Sam for company although
Neville's world-saving quest to create
an antidote gives him long-term purpose
his nurturing and caring for Sam give
him a reason to continue in the daily
basis Sam provides immediate meaning a
series of flashbacks slowly reveal
events before the quarantine
contextualizing Neville's mind set these
flashbacks depict the critical moment
Neville evacuates his wife Zoey and
daughter Marlene then tragedy strikes
when another helicopter collides with
Zoey and Marley's helicopter killing
them shortly before her death Neville
had promised Marley that he would make
the monsters go away it becomes clear
from that point that present-day Neville
is seeking personal salvation and
finding the cure not only for the future
of humanity but also so his family's
death won't be in vain the death of Zoey
and Marley also explains Sam's value
from that moment on sand becomes a
living remnant of nevels old life the
only family member he can love and care
for Bob Marley song three little birds
is intertwined with the theme of I am
Legend the song stands for belief at a
brighter future and inspires neville in
times of need it also facilitates a form
of cathartic escapism the guard's
Neville from insanity his daughter was
named after the cultural icon implying
that long before the end of world events
the original Marley was an inspiration
for Neville a conversation at one point
with fellow survivor Anna near the end
of the film even suggests that Neville
chose his career as a biologist thanks
to Marlon while talking to Anna
Neville says he had this idea it was
kind of a virologists idea he believed
that you could cure racism and hate
literally cure it by injecting music and
love into people's lives in an act of
revenge for trapping a dark seeker for
his tests Neville falls into a trap and
is ambushed by other dark seekers
including canines also infected with the
virus after escaping to the safety of
his home Neville realizes his dog Sam is
infected unlike her owner Sam isn't
immune from the virus in a scene that
would melt the coldest of hearts Neville
is forced to strangle his best friend
and only companion Sam's death alone
doesn't break Neville
it's everything her death represents
she's the tie to his past life a daily
reminder of his motivation to find
Redemption and a buffer between being
alone and experiencing suffocating
loneliness rationality is replaced by
rage when Neville embarks on a suicidal
act of revenge just as Neville is about
to become an evening snack a beam of
light scares the dark seekers away after
three years with no response to his
radio broadcast another face of humanity
has finally arrived however rather than
express gratitude for saving him Neville
is dismissive and struggles to
communicate every single person that you
or I has ever known is dead as I am
Legend reaches its climax the situation
becomes desperate when
large group of dark seekers invade
nevels home Nevel Anna and Ethan flee to
the basement laboratory for safety there
they discover that Neville's antidote is
finally working the dark seekers make
their way to the left with one taking
lead and smashing himself into the glass
partition when the leader smashes
himself into the glass the cracks
resemble a butterfly taking notice at
the butterfly tattoo on Anna's neck
Neville has a realization that this
might indeed be divine intervention this
connects to a gesture from Neville's
daughter Marly earlier in the film
Neville understands this is no
coincidence
after a moment of realization Neville
takes action he draws blood containing
the cure from the dark secret test
subject and gives it to Anna and her son
after seeing that his efforts to make a
cure weren't in vain Neville is now
comfortable paying the ultimate hero
sacrifice to save Anna and even after
Neville's selfless final act Anna and
Ethan make it to the colony and hand
over the vial containing the cure
Neville has become the titular legend in
the alternate ending of I am Legend the
themes of the story are drastically
changed the dark seeker alpha wipes his
own blood onto the glass in the shape of
a butterfly
Neville then turns to the dark seeker
test subject on his table the one he's
cured and notices a butterfly tattoo on
her neck
Neville takes a leap of faith and opens
the glass partition risking his life to
reunite the dark seekers once Neville's
awakened the female the two dark seekers
embrace in a moment of surprising
humanity Smith's character realizes that
the mutants are able to express love and
are closer to humanity than he realized
from the dark seekers perspective
Neville preyed on them kidnapping and
experimenting on their friends family
and loved ones he's a legend but for the
wrong reasons in line with the original
book he has become the monstrous legend
of a new world check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]